[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le meilleur de
l'actualité parlementaire à l'assemblée
au sénat avec à mes côtés en rien de
mancini
bonjour qatar à tous est notre invité
cette semaine et fabien gay bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénateur communiste de
seine-saint-denis merci d'être avec nous
cette semaine et dans l'actualité la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
concernera au maximum six cent mille à
sept cent mille personnes
c'est ce qu'a dit muriel pénicaud
auditionné par les sénateurs la ministre
a contesté les prévisions de l'unedic
qui est estimé à 1,2 million le nombre
de chômeurs concernés par la baisse des
allocations les équipements vétustes et
des conditions de travail détériorées
pour les forces de l'ordre conclusions
de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire qui a passé cinq mois en
immersion avec des policiers et des
gendarmes
le gouvernement serait t'il passé au
vert un projet de loi sur l'énergie et
le climat est débattue au parlement avec
un objectif ambitieux la neutralité
carbone en 2050 un texte pour lutter
contre le gaspillage sera aussi débattue
à la rentrée avec peut-être le retour de
la consigne et puis les sénateurs se
sont penchés sur l'avenir de la
sidérurgie français secteur livrer à la
concurrence des américains et des
chinois
le rapport parlementaire préconise de
redéfinir une stratégie et une politique
industrielle et on commence avec muriel
pénicaud qui était auditionné cette
semaine au sénat
[Musique]
la réforme de l'assurance chômage ne
sera pas votée par le parlement
puisqu'elle passera par décret mais les
sénateurs ont tout de même auditionné la
ministre du travail mme muriel pénicaud
sur cette réforme contestée
fabien becker muriel pénicaud s'est
expliqué devant les sénateurs
alors que l'unedic a calculé qu 1,2
million de chômeurs verront leurs
allocations bcd suite de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
le gouvernement conteste et parle de 700
mille demandeurs d'emploi impactés selon
la ministre
l'organisme public n'a pas tenu compte
des effets psychologiques de la réforme
est ce qu'on attend nous c'est des
changements de comportement et ça c'est
vrai que le ligue ne pouvait pas ne
savait pas le nom pas simuler et donc on
ne compare pas les mêmes choses
évidemment qu'on fait cette réforme pour
qu'il y ait des changements de
comportement que plus de personnes
trouvent un emploi et un emploi précaire
et pour cela le gouvernement poursuit un
principe qui ne soit pas possible de
gagner plus en étant au chômage qu'en
travaillant ce qui serait le cas d'un
demandeur d'emploi sur cinq
d'après l'exécutif la réforme revoit les
règles de calcul des indemnités
dorénavant moins avantageuses pour les
demandeurs d'emploi pas de quoi lutter
contre la précarité selon laurence cohen
membre de la commission des affaires
sociales ces arguments en réalité sont
basées sur le fait qu' ils veulent faire
une économie de plus de 3 milliards sur
le dos des plus fragiles moi j'aimerais
bien que la ministre elle puisse essayer
de s'en sortir pendant un mois avec les
indemnités d'un chômeur puis après ils
reviendraient discuté devant nous la
ministre est en tout cas resté évasif
face à plusieurs questions soulevées par
les sénateurs durant son audition
notamment sur le coût de l'ouverture de
l'assurance chômage à certains
démissionnaires et indépendant fabien
gay comment expliquez vous que la
ministre soit revenu sur les chiffres de
l'unedic qui a fait des erreurs de
calcul ou pas pourquoi ce besoin
d'explication c'est pas si l'unedic
ouzou c'est le gouvernement qui fait des
erreurs de quelqu'un mêmes chiffres
ils ont pas les mêmes chiffres ce qui
est sûr c'est que ces trois milliards
d'économies sur les plus précaires de
notre pays
l'an dernier on a supprimé lisf entre 5
et 6 milliards qui bénéficie aux plus
riches
et là on cherche à jeudi rééquilibrer le
budget de l'état et on le fait commande
sur les chômeurs c'est un des sonneries
sur le dos des chômeurs et jeu ce n'est
pas que les communistes
10 regardez l'ensemble des forces
syndicales même la cfdt est en colère
sur la méthode parce que ça sera par
décret mais aussi sur le fond de la
réforme alors que la cfdt depuis deux
ans est plutôt un soutien de la
politique gouvernementale donc là pour
le coup il ya une unanimité en front
syndical mais aussi plus largement on
l'a vu lors de la commission certains
nombres de sénatrices et sénateurs de
tous bords ont posé des questions à
madame pénicaud en vérité elle s'attaque
aux chômeurs et non pas au chômage
c'est ça la réalité et donc vous allez
avoir un problème c'est que vous allez
précarisés de plus en plus de gens sur
un fond d'eux
de toute façon ce sont les mêmes qui
vous disent qu'il suffit de traverser la
route pour trouver un emploi cie
baptisation décrit bien sûr ces
tribunaux stigmatisation des chômeurs
pour recharger ses droits il faudra
travailler plus longtemps
il va falloir sur le calcul il faudra
travailler plus mais en moins de temps
donc en réalité
moi ce que j'appelle c'est qu'il nous
faut pas réformer l'assurance chômage
il nous faut réformer l'emploi parce que
vous vont trouver un emploi les gens à
conforama qui est en train de licencier
à auchan à carrefour arjowiggins voyez
bien ceci n'est pas possible il faut une
réforme du marché de l'emploi sur la
question des aides publiques qui
aujourd'hui permettent de licencier pour
les grands groupes et non pas d'investir
dans l'investissement et dans l'emploi
et les salaires pour soutenir l'économie
parce que voyez c'est un marché global
et puis sur un certain nombre de
filières industrielles
il faut que l'état oublié une maîtrise
publique on a eu il ya quinze jours sur
la scène j'ai ça c'est un avenir
aujourd'hui mais on s'aperçoit que le
marché se séparent entre les chinois et
les américains nous qu'est ce que nous
avons fait depuis 15 ans nous avons
démantelé france télécom nous avons
vendu alcatel à nokia et il n'y a plus
de filières industrielles sur ce sujet
d'avenir
est-ce que nous prenons ce ce sujet là
la deuxième chose nous parlerons du
projet energy sse fini mais il n'y a pas
de filière industrielle sur les énergies
renouvelables
est ce qu'il ya une maîtrise et on
permet que des filières industrielles se
développe pour que l'emploi parce que
franchement et je finis par là dire que
c'est parce qu'on va précariser les gens
qu'on va les pousser à aller au travail
ça c'est la méthode anglo saxon et ce
n'est pas vrai en réalité il ya plus de
travailleurs pauvres
voilà à quoi veut nous mener ce
gouvernement sur cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage
ap a quand même du bon les bonus malus
sur les courts en bonus malus mais vous
avez vu que sur cette branche
professionnelle par exemple dans le même
temps on exclut la propreté mais en même
temps on a une grande déclaration de
madame marlène schiappa pour nous dire
moi il ya quinze jours
- les femmes de ménage je vais les avoir
à coeur et je veux les soutenir si elle
voulait les soutenir il fallait que la
broche professionnels de l'hygiène soit
sur le bonus malus
ça aurait été une véritable avancée
alors bien sûr tout est à jeter
non j'ai dit que sur les bonus malus sur
les sept branches professionnelles
il ya notamment la restauration et
l'hôtellerie c'est une bonne chose même
jamais aimé oui mais ce n'est pas
suffisant vous voyez c'est que ça
concerne que cette branche
professionnelle l'hôtel l'hôtellerie et
la restauration mais derrière on a on à
la pub
bon franchement le medef a voulu que ce
soit très restreints à quelques secteurs
ce n'est pas là il faut étendre par
exemple le système de bonus malus
rapidement vous parlez de l'emploi les
chiffres du chômage sont plutôt bons ils
pourraient être 2003 fin 2019 le chômage
baisse ah bon
quand les chiffres du chômage oui mon
meilleur mais ce cas la leur aussi
laissé si oui oui je les conteste
parce que la précarité s'étend dans
notre pays voyez quand vous auditionner
les associations s'y trompe l'oeil pour
vous sécher bien sûr parce qu'on veille
les gens car lorsqu'on veille les gens
vous voyez on veille
mais quand vous voyez les gens les gens
ils vivent toujours ils ont des noms des
prénoms et des visages voyez faire
surveiller d'un fichier et la précarité
s'étend dans notre pays quand vous avez
vous auditionner les associations
caritatives vous le disent qu'il n'y a
jamais eu autant de précarité chez les
jeunes mais aussi chez les retraités
il ya des retraités qui dans ce pays
aujourd'hui n'arrive pas vivre dignement
leur retraite et seront obligés d'aller
reprendre un emploi
vous trouvez ça normal moi non eh bien
on va passer à un autre sujet fabien gay
puisque l assemblée une commission
denquête à évaluer les conditions de
travail de la police et de la
gendarmerie cinq mois en immersion 250
auditions et un rapport sans équivoque
[Musique]
un système proche de la rupture des
conditions de travail dégradées des
forces de l'ordre le constat de ce
rapport parlementaire sur les missions
et moyens des forces de sécurité est
sans appel
maïté frais non des cafards des
toilettes d'inonder ou encore des
voitures en très mauvais état
deux ans après ces photos prises par des
policiers c'est au tour des
parlementaires de tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé pour ce rapport ils ont été 13
1735 à témoigner des policiers des
gendarmes des réservistes
tous font état d'une situation critique
déjà maintes fois dénoncé ce qui les
inquiète ce sont d'abord leur logement
le chiffre est éloquent
80% des casernes ont par exemple plus de
50 ans leur véhicule aussi sont jugé
vieillissants plus de sept ans c'est
l'âge moyen d'une voiture de la police
nationale
le rapport préconise donc de rajeunir le
parc automobile ce qui coûterait 40
millions d'euros au minimum
autre conclusion la mise en avant de
l'accumulation des heures
supplémentaires cent soixante quatre
heures en moyenne par agent de la police
ce qui représente pour les ressources
humaines plus de 272 millions d'euros
les tâches administratives sont
également pointés du doigt 28 heures
c'est le temps en moyenne consacré pour
rédiger une procédure une activité trop
complexes qui se multiplient pour les
forces de l'ordre pour améliorer leurs
conditions de travail 27 propositions
ont été retenues parmi lesquels moins de
lourdeurs administratives et bien sûr
plus de moyens avec à la clé des
recrutements d'effectifs
fabien gay vous avez vu ces images ces
chiffres révélés par ce rapport
parlementaire qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
c'est un excellent rapport fait par dont
deux collègues de l'assemblée nationale
eu un membre de l'ue dit et l'autre de
république en marche l'ancien patron du
raid mais je vois là mais j'ai envie de
vous dire que je n'ai rien appris
excellent rapport qui nous remet une
situation que nous connaissons déjà
parce qu'il suffit d'aller porter
plainte dans un commissariat et on voit
les conditions de travail des agents
donc la sonnette d'alarmé est tirée
maintenant depuis des années et comment
vous expliquez que rien n'est rien je
vais vous dire c'est que nous pouvons
collectionner les rapports mais après
c'est qu'est ce que nous en faisons là
nous avons un excellent apport qui nous
dit grosso modo je n'allais pas tout à
fait le même chiffre il dit 50 millions
d'euros on pourrait se remettre à niveau
notamment sur la question des
casernements parce que c'est un
véritable scandale
mais après soit on prend le rapport et
puis on va le mettre sous une
bibliothèque pour caler les armoires
mais oui mais par exemple on pourrait
citer le rapport de nos collègues aussi
ici sur les services publics en seine
saint denis qui faisait police justice
éducation et il disait que c'était un
désert et que même les cols la mieux
dotée de seine saint denis était de
toute façon pire que lapierre école de
paris voyait donc des rapports ils sont
successifs mais il arrive dans la vie
d'un parlementaire je crois que c'est
entre eux octobre novembre et décembre
ça s'appelle le budget voyez donc on
fait des rapports de janvier à octobre
on est tous et toutes d'accord on les
votes des deux mers tout le monde dit
mais il manque des moyens pour les
services publics
et après ils arrivent le budget de
l'état et là il ya moins de mains qui se
lèvent quand il suffit de dire mais
augmentant le budget pour nos policiers
pourquoi demande d'expliquer augmentant
par exemple non pitié pour les hôpitaux
parce qu alain brunel député du nord
vous avez vu il a passé six heures dans
les urgences et il a dit que les
conditions de travail étaient exécrables
pour les médecins et les infirmières
donc il faut à prélever la mer voyez
lors des budgets pour dire augmente on
est là il ya une contradiction forte
par exemple nos collègues de droite et
dans marche que vont-ils faire lors du
budget 2010 9
est ce qu'ils vont dire au ministre
bruno le maire a remercié entamé un bras
de fer pour dire il faut les 50 millions
de rattrapage
oui ou non moi je m'y engage lieu je
pense que les communistes ici à
l'assemblée nationale comme au sénat s'y
engageront mais vous voyez après ça sera
peut-être plus compliqué pour les droite
sénatoriale
l'ailé droite dc de l'assemblée sécurité
des français est en jeu contre voit les
policiers les gens de travailler dans
des conditions comme ça pour vous mais
oui mais attendez moi je suis du
blanc-mesnil voyez quand je vais au
commissariat ça m'est déjà arrivé une ou
deux fois dans l'année et qu'ils me
disent qu'ils n'ont même pas de voiture
pour trôner la nuit parce que soit ils
n'ont pas la voiture soit ils ne sont
pas si nombreux au commissariat bah oui
c'est la sécurité de l'ensemble des
habitants mais aussi la leur qui est en
péril et donc ça va craquer mais je le
redis la droite sénatoriale proposé 500
mille fonctionnaires en moins emmanuel
macron demi cent cinquante mille
fonctionnaires en moins il ya une
contradiction
là je le dis ce rapport là il faut pas
qu'il reste lettre morte
il faut le pousser jusqu'au budget de
l'état et on verra qui votera envoyé et
je vous fais confiance à donner les noms
de qui votera pour et qu'il est bien
dans son bras tout simplement la haye
les autres sujets le gouvernement qui
cherche à verdir sa politique avec de
loi sur l'écologie
[Musique]
et tout d'abord le projet doit énergie
climat apporté par françois de rugy déjà
voté à l'assemblée nationale il sera
examiné en séance au sénat la semaine
prochaine
mais la chambre haute a apporté des
modifications aurélia romano le projet
de loi énergie climat affiche des
objectifs ambitieux à l'issue du vote à
l'assemblée avant d'arriver au sénat dès
2022 fermeture des centrales à charbon
dès 2035 diminution de la part du
nucléaire à 50% et atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 ses objectifs
de long terme ne sont pas assez concret
pour la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat qui a introduit des
étapes intermédiaires notamment sur la
production d'hydroélectricité sur
l'éolien en mer ou encore sur le gaz sur
le gaz pareil on a donné des objectifs
et dancette ppe programmation on n'est
même pas dans la trajectoire de
l'objectif de 10% de de biogaz non là
encore je crains tu dans du réalisme il
faut donner des ambitions des chiffres
atteignable mais surtout donné ni limité
de l'action autre apport du sénat chaque
dispositif devra inclure un bilan
carbone un outil indicatif qui devrait
permettre de prendre mieux conscience du
coût réel de chaque équipement
énergétique s'est pas uniquement
l'installation sur un territoire qui
doit être prise en compte c'est aussi sa
fabrication
les conditions dans lesquelles cette cet
outil permettant de produire de
l'énergie renouvelable a été réalisée
sur le nucléaire en revanche le sénat
n'est pas allé plus loin que le
gouvernement les sénateurs écologistes
le regrette et attendre le débat en
séance afin de proposer de nouveaux
amendements
ça sera une discussion en séance de voir
si on a un des plafonds de production
nucléaire plus précis pour forcer
effectivement à cette réduction et pour
que les 12 14 réacteurs annoncé comme
devant fermer pour 2035 soit vraiment
des fermetures obligatoire parce qu'on
aura mis des plafonds de production
nucléaire dans la loi les écologistes
déplorent aussi un recul du sénat sur la
lutte contre les logements énergivores
appelé passoires thermiques en
commission la sanction prévue contre les
propriétaires et remplacée par une phase
dite incitative
une manière de repousser les travaux
nécessaires
est-ce que vous pensez que ce texte est
plutôt assez ambitieux ou contraire pas
du tout ambitieux c'est très compliqué
parce que l'ambition nous la partageons
par exemple la neutralité carbone à
l'horizon 2050 je crois que tout le
monde est pour moi je suis un écologiste
convaincu et c'est pour ça que je suis
communiste je pense que l'humain et la
planète ça doit être notre combat
quotidien et sur une à venir de long
terme sur les questions d'énergie de
transport de rénovation des logements
tout ça il faut s'y attaquer parce que
si nous ne faisons rien dans dix ans le
pouvoir politique ne pourra plus rien
faire
il y aura des conséquences irréversibles
pour notre planète donc c'est maintenant
qu'il faut changer notre système changer
nos productions
alors là oui c'est toujours pareil il ya
une ambition forte voyez c'est comme une
pastèque
elle est verte à l'extérieur mais quand
au louvre c'est plus la même couleur
mais c'est pareil c'est la même chose
là vous avez pas les moyens comment on
n'y arrive pas les filières
industrielles par exemple moi je suis
pour qu'un mix énergétique les énergies
renouvelables progressent mais nous
avons une question quelles filières
industrielles pour créer par exemple les
éoliennes offshore les seuls qui ont été
faits à saint lazare et tous attendent
encore le peu de moyens pour se
développer
voyez donc on peut avoir des belles
ambitions mais derrière il faut que ça
suive et il faut mettre de l'argent il
ya des experts qui disent que c'est 400
milliards sur les trente prochaines
années qu'il faut investir massivement
pour changer notre modèle mais on n'a
pas l'once d'un premier centime dans ce
projet de loi et puis je le dis nous
avons un débat de fond est ce que nous
pensons que c'est le privé qui va
pouvoir régler tout cela
ou est-ce qu'il faut une maîtrise
publique parce que dans le même temps
vous votez énergie climat
je vous dis deux points vous êtes en
train de démanteler edf en deux filières
la filière énergie nucléaire
aujourd'hui comme c'est elle qui est
déficitaire voulant nationalisée puis
les énergies non renouvelables et la
distribution vous la livrer aux marchés
et puis quand vous parlez de neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050
mais quand même temps vous êtes ici en
train de ratifier le ceta à l'assemblée
nationale et que l'union européenne
vient de signer l'accord avec le
mercosur dont on sait les dégâts que ça
va faire pour nos agri notre agriculture
pour new danger sanitaire et sociale
pour les normes environnementales tout
ceci vous voyez n'est pas sérieux c'est
une cohérence d'ensemble et encore une
fois il ya des belles ambitions mais les
actes nous trahissent
sur les parages le gouvernement un mot
sur les passeurs thermique en vie et
c'est l'un des pans de ce texte oui ce
que pour vous il faut sanctionner les
propriétaires de ces logements
il faut un plan marshall un plan
marshall maintenant si on rénove au même
rythme que le fait aujourd'hui
vous savez combien il faudrait d'années
140 dans 140 ans pour venir à bout des
sept millions et demi de passoires
thermiques qui n'ont le territoire et
ses les plus précaires qui habitent ces
passoires thermiques donc en vérité vous
fait peser une double menace sur eux
donc il faut un plan marshall elle
vestiaires massivement je suis pour
qu'on incite au maximum pendant
peut-être jusqu'en 2025 et qu'ensuite
nous passons nous passions à des
sanctions
il faut laisser ces temps voilà ça
pourrait être déjà vous voyez ces temps
on n'est pas quand même sur le bâton et
puis après passer à des sanctions
oui parce que mais il faut inciter
massivement allez on passe au sénat
qu'il se penche sur l'avenir de la
filière sidérurgie
[Musique]
la mission d'information sénatoriale sur
l'avenir de la sidérurgie a remis son
rapport cette semaine la filière a des
atouts mais souffre d'une mauvaise image
le sénat fait plusieurs préconisations
pour aider cette filière jérôme
rhabiller la filière sidérurgique
français subit depuis des années les
mutations mondiales du secteur face aux
états unis qui pratiquent le dumping ou
à la chine qui produit désormais plus de
la moitié de l'acier mondial la france a
pourtant des atouts
la mission d'information sur cette
filière stratégique pour toute
l'industrie préconise dans son rapport
de beaucoup mieux accompagner les
acteurs du secteur pour ne pas sombrer
d'ici quelques années la filière
sidérurgique française comme européenne
j'ai une crise importante de
surcapacités mondiales de fermeture d'un
certain nombre de marchés et d'une
incapacité delà de l'europe notamment de
réagir suffisamment rapidement pour
protéger son industrie sidérurgique pour
le président et la rapporteure les
réponses doivent être européenne et
française avec par exemple
l'instauration d'une taxe carbone aux
frontières de l'ue eux pour ne pas
pénaliser l'acier français est encore en
développement une vraie spécificité
française de recyclage de ce métal et
pour les sénateurs l'état ne doit pas
intervenir seulement quand les choses
vont mal
comme sur le dossier à ce qu'au val mais
développer une vraie stratégie
sidérurgique française il faut changer
de braquet
il faut prendre toute la dimension du
besoin de nos industries de la
sidérurgie un ministère de l'industrie
c'est maintenant parce que c'est
maintenant qu'il faut prendre toute la
dimension de cet enjeu à xiii sera trop
tard car si la filière pâti d'une
mauvaise image du aux fermetures par
exemple des hauts fourneaux de florange
où des difficultés d'ascq ovale elle
emploie encore trente huit mille
personnes en france et peine à trouver
des profils alors qu'elle prévoit 5600
recrutements d'ici 2025
voilà pour ce bien sombre tableau est ce
que vous pensez
fabien gay que la l'état encore quelque
chose pour la sidérurgie en france face
au géant chinois et américains et à
leurs stratégies
bah oui j'ai fait partie de cette
mission est menée je le dis avec brio
par madame l'état et monsieur lennon
ville et on a d'ailleurs on est tombé
d'accord sur un certain nombre de points
est-ce qui a besoin d'acier dans le
futur ou pas c'est ça la question oui
parce que pour faire notamment la
transition écologique il faudra de
l'acier sur le secteur automobile
donc est-ce qu'il faut mieux que ça soit
construit en france et en union
européenne
ou plutôt en chine ou au brésil aux
états unis tout est là la question
nous nous pensons qu'ils aient un avenir
pour une filière industrielle en france
et construire des champions européens
mais pour cela il faut d'abord qu'ils
ministre de l'industrie qui s'occupe des
questions pour la mise en place d'un
ministère de l'industrie attendait le
problème qu'on a en france depuis
maintenant avec ce gouvernement c'est
qu'en vérité vous n'avez plus de
ministre de l'industrie donc c'est le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
qui à chaque fois qu'il ya un problème
lui prend le dossier mais il n'y a pas
un ministre de l'industrie qui a une
vision d'avenir pour impulser notamment
les filières et notamment sur la
question sidérurgique questions
d'actualité en toujours parlementaire
cette semaine
adp aéroports de paris que le
gouvernement veut privatiser un
référendum
et vous demander un référendum la
collecte de signatures est en cours
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement freine cette collecte de
signatures il en faut quatre millions 7
il n'y a pas de mots un an nous avons
été d'abord ces parties du c'est là
puisque le sénat a voté contre
pendant leur pacte puis ensuite mais à
voter une deuxième fois contre et
ensuite et est née l'idée d'avoir un
référendum d'initiative partagée qui
faisait écho un peu au mouvement social
pour plus de démocratie
248 parlementaires de toute entrave de
tous bords sauf la république à marche
en co signée cette proposition de
référendum et franchement depuis le 13
juin la mise en place sans en vérité de
débats sur les chaînes publiques
ce que nous demandons sans que le
ministère de l'intérieur joue le jeu je
le dis comme ça franchement on a un site
internet qui ressemble plus que plus un
skyblog des années 2000 plus qu au site
internet hotels je sais qu'ils
entraînent des pieds voilà on va le dire
franchement tout était sur les rails
pour privatiser adp pour faire cadeau à
26 mai aux copains et bien maintenant
ceci prend un mauvais virage et dans ces
conditions en 24 jours cinq cent mille
personnes ont déjà cosigné cette
proposition de référendum
c'est un exploit et je peux vous dire ça
va s'arrêter oui faut 4 millions 710
1396 signature précisément pendant neuf
mois nous menons une campagne des forces
associatives syndicales sont mobilisé
plus de 100 organisations
nous demandons maintenant la mise en
place d'un comité de suivi à monsieur
castaner nous étions d'ailleurs une
trentaine de parlementaires à la place
beauvau hier pour exiger la mise en
place de ce comité de suivi et nous
demandons que les chaînes publiques
fassent une promotion de ce référendum
la question n'est pas oui ou non vous
êtes pour la privatisation non non non
la question est est ce que nous donnons
la parole au peuple
c'est une question démocratique depuis
1986 il y a eu 1500 privatisation 1500
on n'a jamais demandé son avis au peuple
là vous avez l'occasion prenez la parole
signé cette proposition de loi
référendaire très bien des petites
questions avant de terminer cette
émission sur françois de rugy qui est
donc dans la tourmente après les
révélations dans la presse au sujet de
ses dépenses et dîners jugé fastueux à
l'hôtel de lassay au temps où il était
président
l'assemblée est ce que vous pensez que
ces révélations ces agissements sont de
nature à abîmer l'image du parlement et
des parlementaires
or deux choses moi j'aime jamais hurlé
avec les loups mais là franchement c'est
inacceptable je le dis comme ça c'est
les mêmes qui vous font des grandes
leçons sur la probité en politique sur
on est le nouveau monde sur les gilet
jaune
il faut qu'ils se taisent parce qu'avais
mille balles par mois on vit bien mais
ils ont qu'à faire et quand les gens
voient qu'on s'empiffre de homard de
grandes crues tout ça aux frais de la
princesse pour eux c'est inacceptable
donc bon voilà après chacun en tire les
conséquences moi je ne suis pas de ceux
qui demandent la démission le
remplacement tout ça les gens prennent
leur responsabilité a priori non mais
franchement
ceux ci ne donne pas une bonne image il
ya eu la sphère benalla l'été dernier
c'est la sphère de rugy cette année bon
mais voilà chacun en tire les
conséquences
mais est il encore un crédible en tant
que ministre français d'origine arabe et
c'est quand même un de ceux qui nous
donnent des grandes leçons à longueur de
journée il n y en a une grande réforme
d'ailleurs il faudrait un jour faire le
bilan de cette grande réforme
vous voyez pas ce que j'aurai beaucoup
de choses à dire parce qu'on a interdit
par exemple que les collégiens de soi
collaborateur collaboratrice
mais en fait on s'aperçoit c'est dans la
presse qu en fait en fait ils se sont
échangés voyez il y en a certains qui
sont devenus les collaborateurs et
collaboratrices de d'autres députés
donc si c'est ça la république
exemplaire sans cesse nos croyances mais
il reste encore à faire elle savait il
reste beaucoup à faire mais pas avec les
gens qui s'empiffrent de caviar et dowaq
et de groupes ce sera le mot de la fin
merci fabien cadavre était l'invité de
cette émission merci oriane dernière
mission ensemble en rien ne vous
retrouve l'an prochain aux commandes de
la matinale c'est la fin de cette
émission très bonne 7e programme
[Musique]